well ross mr sag ambassador how are you
today you look dapper oh thank you
coming from you that means a lot well
listen this is amazing i actually am
kind of getting all the feels from being
here seeing folks in person being back
to what feels a little bit like a
community right yes no it's so great to
be in the same room without masks with
all my peers so i can actually see
all the smiles that's only if i make
them smile i guess i guess if they look
at me they're just going to be like yeah
no no no no because we got to get down
to the brass tacks with you so you've
got a fury of the gods up next right yes
ma'am so tell me what can we expect oh i
mean i can't say too much but uh what i
can say is that helen mirren and lucy
liu have jumped on i got to meet them in
the same day that's all you really have
to say is that yeah
yeah i mean
they're both just legends absolute
legends so like yeah so uh and then yeah
you get to see more of the kids this
time because the kids came on at the end
of the first movie so now you get to see
more of her powers get to see us
interact more so yeah it's gonna be
great so you worked with helen and lucy
in the same day like you shot with both
of them in the same day oh yeah that is
a big one oh yeah i won't say for what
but you're guys gonna you're gonna be
that was my follow-up yeah
i'll tell you i'll tell you
so helen of course is being honored with
the lifetime achievement award tonight
just talk about i mean
her as the icon that she is she's just
had such a prolific career i i'm looking
forward so much to hearing what she has
to say because you know getting a
lifetime achievement award
maybe she won't say too much but like
that's something that you really want to
think about what you say and like and
what you're gonna like what goes along
with receiving that so um yeah i just uh
she's such an amazing person and so
humble and yeah i can't wait to hear she
without being able to think of another
word she's just the coolest broad in the
room right yeah she just did took the
words right out of my mouth the coolest
broad in the room now five years ago if
i would have said you're starring in a
roku miniseries it might have sounded
weird but now that everything is
streaming
it's of the norm tell me about this mini
series so swimming with sharks it's
based off the old movie about hollywood
and the crazy stuff that goes on yeah
this is just a modern take and it's a
more female perspective uh with kiernan
shipka and diane kruger and um yeah we
shot that
during kovid like when we still didn't
really know what covid was and we're
trying to figure stuff out so uh yeah
we're trying to i can't wait to see it
it's premiering at south by southwest
nice we're going to be there in austin
texas i don't know if you've ever been
but i have i've been to south by so many
times that boston is one of my favorite
cities
i'm ready to get some of that barbecue
some terry blacks i got to go back you
know one of the things i like so much is
when they say to the actors like you
know that they open it up and the actors
say hi i'm so-and-so and i'm an actor
and i got myself where did you get your
sag card oh my god
so
um the first thing that got me my sad
card was a uh there's a show called
major crimes on tnt it's like a police
procedural i played a high school drug
dealer that also like got into stanford
so i was kind of like a punk and i was
getting grilled by and it was a really
memorable moment because um i was like
yeah i guess this is uh this is my
typecast i'm just gonna be typecast as
that smart drug dealer kid
but thank god i broke out of that really
uh but yeah that's what got my my sad
card